it was
irresponsible absolutely they spent what
a trillion dollars plus countless man
hours not to mention political Capital
trying to get one dude back from Mars
political Capital it United the world
yeah for a hot second but what if they
failed everyone would have been like um
excuse me you know there are people
dying here right people are always dying
on Earth you can't change that but if
you get the opportunity to bring back
Matt Damon no screw Matt Damon that's
just harsh dude it costs an average
$1,200 to Save a Life what when you give
money to charity the ones that are
actually going to save lives are the
ones that clean water and give out
medicine and stuff right M Damon's
charity literally cleans water so when
you factor in administrative costs and
how many people would actually die
without help that works out to 1,200
bucks for life okay so what you're
saying is you take a trillion and divide
it by 1,200 and you can save
833 million people's lives on
Earth you just do that math right now
I'm wicked smart I know it's just you
look like so dumb
okay
Checkmate dang
boom
okay you really don't think this ending
anybody to save
us I
mean I'm sure they're doing what they
can within
[Music]
reason